en el modelo de borde el átomo de
hidrógeno tenemos un electrón que se
encuentra orbitando alrededor del núcleo
a cierta distancia r muy bien así que en
el modelo de vor el electrón está en
órbita está en órbita en órbita muy bien
entonces en la versión de la mecánica
cuántica del átomo de hidrógeno no
sabemos con precisión dónde se encuentra
el electrón pero podríamos decir que con
una alta probabilidad verdad el electrón
se encuentra en un orbital muy bien
entonces el electrón está en
orbital y un orbital esencialmente es
una región del espacio en donde el
electrón tiene una mayor probabilidad de
ser encontrado verdad para el hidrógeno
podríamos imaginar una esfera ok
alrededor del núcleo más o menos esto
sería como
esfera es como un cuerpo sólido en tres
dimensiones y el electrón se encuentra
en algún lugar de esta esfera verdad es
más probable que lo encontremos en esta
en esta región así que tenemos estas dos
visiones que digamos hasta cierto punto
compiten por un lado tenemos el modelo
el modelo de vor que es el que utiliza
la mecánica clásica y el electrón orbita
el núcleo y de la misma forma que los
planetas orbitan alrededor del sol pero
en la versión de la mecánica cuántica
decimos que no sabemos con exactitud
dónde se encuentra el electrón y el
modelo de hbo resulta ser incorrecto
verdad
este modelo resulta ser incorrecto y la
mecánica cuántica
ha probado ser una mejor forma para
explicar los electrones en orbitales y
podemos describir dichos electrones en
orbital esencialmente usando los cuatro
números cuánticos así que fijémonos en
el primer número cuántico por aquí
que sería el número cuántico principal y
que vamos a denotar con la letra n y de
hecho n es un entero positivo así que me
podría ser igual a 123 y así podríamos
seguir en adelante y n indicã el nivel
principal de energía que está ocupado
por el electrón verdad y esto nos dice
esencialmente el nivel principal de
energía en el que se encuentra el
electrón muy bien entonces nos dice el
nivel principal de energía en el que se
encuentra el electrón y quizás también
lo has oído digamos o se han referido a
él en alguna clase como una capa a veces
también le podríamos llamar capa así que
a medida que n aumenta la distancia
promedio del electrón hacia el núcleo
incrementa también y de ahí que la
energía también aumenta así que por
ejemplo si tuviéramos aquí el núcleo
a tomo muy bien aquí tendríamos el
núcleo del átomo y pensemos por ahora
que n es igual a 1 n es igual a 1
entonces tendríamos que en promedio por
ejemplo la distancia del núcleo al
electrón sería más o menos ésta sería
ésta la distancia promedio
ahora vamos a compararla con el caso en
el que n es igual a 2 digamos que me
fuera igual a 2
eso significa que tendríamos un nivel de
energía mayor y en promedio el electrón
está más lejos del núcleo verdad
entonces en promedio el electrón se
encuentra más lejos del núcleo y está
hay un hay una mayor cantidad de energía
asociada con esto verdad y esa es la
idea principal del número cuántico
estamos pensando en los niveles de
energía o las capas
y de esta misma forma estamos pensando
en la distancia promedio del núcleo al
electrón así que vamos con el segundo
número cuántico
vamos con el segundo número cuántico que
es el número cuántico de momento angular
y en este caso vamos a referirnos a él
con la letra l y la l lo que nos indica
esencialmente es la forma del orbital es
la forma del orbital esto nos va a decir
cuál es la figura o la forma del orbital
y los valores para el led son
dependientes de d el número n que
habíamos elegido antes así que los
valores de l los valores de l van desde
cero
2 y así sucesivamente hasta n menos 1
muy bien así que por ejemplo si pensamos
en el caso en el que fuera uno entonces
él le tendría que ir desde cero hasta
uno menos uno que vuelve a ser cero
entonces solo hay un valor posible para
él y es el caso en que l es igual a cero
y cuando él es igual a cero llamamos a
este orbital le llamamos un orbital s un
orbital ese y la forma de los orbitales
es esencialmente es esférica es como si
tuviéramos una esfera voy a hacerlo un
poco más pequeño
tendremos una figura esférica verdad una
figura esférica que por supuesto es un
objeto es un volumen en tres dimensiones
muy bien y que de hecho ya hemos hablado
un poquito de ello cuando estábamos
viendo el átomo de hidrógeno así que
simplemente hay que imaginar esto como
una esfera como un volumen de tres
dimensiones ahora cuando el número
cuántico de momento angular l
cuando el número cuántico del momento
angular el es igual a 0 corresponde a un
orbital ese muy bien a un orbital ese y
el electrón tiene una digamos es más
probable que lo encontremos en esta
región esférica verdad así que vamos a
fijarnos en la siguiente en el siguiente
caso digamos en la siguiente capa en
cuando n es igual a 2
entonces según nuestra regla él le puede
tomar distintos valores que van desde 0
hasta n menos 1 pero en es 2 así que va
desde 0 hasta 1 y por ejemplo 100 es 22
menos 1 es uno sólo tenemos dos posibles
valores para l que es 0 y 1 algo por
ejemplo interesante que podríamos
observar es que el número de valores
posibles para él siempre coincide con
nuestro número nba así que por ejemplo
en este caso en es igual a 1 y en este
caso él es solo tiene un valor posible
que es 0 en el siguiente caso en es
igual a 2
tenemos dos valores posibles que son 0 y
1 ahora bien ya hemos hablado en el caso
en que el es igual a 0 en este caso
tendríamos que si él es igual a cero
tenemos un orbital ese y tiene una forma
esférica
sin embargo digamos si tuviéramos que l
es igual a 1 entonces estaríamos
hablando de que tenemos un orbital p
y la forma de los orbitales p es un
poquito un poquito extraña así que voy a
tratar de despojarlo por aquí más o
menos se ve como algo así que podríamos
pensar que es como como una especie de
de moño o una pesa con la cual uno hace
ejercicio pero esencialmente son como
dos esferas achatadas en un punto muy
bien y recordemos nuevamente que esto es
una figura en tres dimensiones verdad
tiene volumen tiene volumen esta figura
muy bien
quizás incluso en ocasiones podrás
escuchar los siguientes términos por
ejemplo cuando tenemos en igualados
estamos pensando que nos encontramos en
una capa verdad sin embargo aunque
estamos en esta capa aunque estamos en
esta capa estamos también en dos
distintas sub capas verdad tendríamos
dos distintas sub capas
capas es decir cuando él es igual a 0
tendríamos la sub capa que corresponde a
un orbital ese y cuando él es igual a 1
orbitales p muy bien ahora vamos a
fijarnos en el siguiente número cuántico
que sería el número cuántico magnético y
ahora en este caso vamos a denotar lo
con la letra m con un subíndice l muy
bien y m sub
l nos indica la orientación de un
orbital alrededor del núcleo muy bien
esto nos da la orientación vamos a poner
solo eso la orientación del orbital
alrededor del núcleo nuevamente los
valores de ml dependerán ahora del valor
que tengamos para él sólito verdad así
que ml será igual a un valor digamos ml
puede tomar cualquier valor entero que
vaya desde menos l que vaya desde menos
l hasta l positivo muy bien son valores
enteros negativos o positivos o
positivos y esto puede sonar un poquito
confuso así que vamos a hacer un ejemplo
para él por ejemplo cuando él es igual a
cero así que por ejemplo si si él es
igual a cero ok qué pasaría si tenemos
que l es igual a cero entonces el valor
de ml nos dice que puede ir desde menos
l hasta más el entonces ml va desde
menos 0 hasta más 0 entonces realmente
sólo tenemos una posibilidad que ml
valga 0 verdad y si estamos hablando
retomemos que cuando cuando hablamos de
que él es igual a 0 estamos pensó
en un orbital ese y que tiene la forma
de una esfera verdad y si pensamos en
eso realmente sólo hay un valor posible
para el número cuántico magnético y eso
nos dice que la orientación en realidad
sólo hay una orientación en este caso
verdad para el orbital alrededor del
núcleo y eso tiene sentido verdad porque
si colocamos aquí esta esfera digamos en
este espacio de tres dimensiones verdad
en este espacio de tres dimensiones en
realidad sólo tenemos una posible
orientación y esa es la idea del número
cuántico magnético ahora vamos a hacer
otros ejemplos
digamos
y estos ejemplos de abajo
hagamos la misma idea para cuando l es
igual a 1 muy bien así que si nos
fijamos en esto cuando él es igual a 1
vamos a utilizar vamos a utilizar otro
color para este caso en el que l es
igual a 1
entonces las posibilidades para el
número cuántico magnético ml sólo son
tres verdad porque podríamos ir desde
menos uno hasta más uno entonces
tendremos menos 10 y 1 positivo así que
tenemos solo tres posibles valores menos
10 y más 11 23 posibles valores y
sabemos que el número cuántico magnético
nos dice las orientaciones posibles para
los orbitales verdad o bien digamos de
forma más precisa las orientaciones
posibles de los orbitales alrededor del
núcleo así que tenemos tres valores lo
cual significa que tenemos tres
distintas orientaciones y ya hemos dicho
que cuando él es igual a uno
estamos hablando de orbitales p muy bien
cuando él es igual a uno hablamos de
orbitales p que tienen forma como
demonio así que tenemos tres distintas
orientaciones que podríamos colocar en
estos ejes así que digamos que aquí
coloco los ejes x
iceta una forma de orientar este orbital
p sería poniendo nuestro moño alrededor
del eje x y no olvidemos que estas son
figuras en tres dimensiones verdad estas
son figuras en tres dimensiones y tienen
volumen entonces al orientarlo de esta
forma podríamos decir que este orbital p
es un orbital px nuevamente si ponemos
aquí el nombre de los ejes que esté
fuera de eje x eje y y eje z
podríamos sobre orientar nuestro orbital
p alrededor del eje y verdad nuevamente
esto tiene volumen y entonces a este
orbital podríamos llamarle el orbital
pegue y finalmente si nuevamente
colocamos los nombres de nuestros ejes
podríamos orientar el orbital p
alrededor del eje zeta
recordemos tiene volumen y por lo tanto
a este orbital le podemos llamar el
orbital pz entonces esto fue para el
número cuántico magnético vámonos con el
último número cuántico que sería el
número cuántico de espn y que ahora
vamos a denotar con con m sub s y en
realidad cuando dice spin voy a ponerlo
entre comillas verdad porque esto parece
parece que implica que un electrón está
girando alrededor de un eje y no es
realmente lo que está ocurriendo pero
pero de esta forma podríamos dibujar dos
versiones del electrón así que podríamos
tener dos versiones del del electrón y
podríamos pensar que está girando como
un trompo verdad así que este primer
electrón puede girar alrededor del eje
digamos en estas dos formas y nuevamente
esto no es lo que ocurre en la realidad
en los electrones no giran alrededor de
los ejes como si fueran un trompo pero
al menos esto nos ayuda a pensar en el
hecho de
tenemos dos posibles valores para este
número cuántico de espn así que
podríamos decir que el número cuántico
de espn puede ser igual a m es igual a
un medio positivo aunque generalmente lo
escucharás que le llaman el spin hacia
arriba aunque vamos a poner que esto es
el spin hacia arriba y en vídeos
posteriores lo vamos a denotar con una
flecha que apunta justamente hacia
arriba y ese sería el primer valor
posible para el número cuántico de espn
ahora viene el otro posible valor del
número cuántico de espn sería un medio
negativo al cual nos vamos a referir
como el spin hacia abajo y que a
diferencia del caso anterior vamos a
denotar con una flecha que justamente
apunta hacia abajo y nuevamente los
electrones no están girando realmente
digamos en un sentido físico como este
que tenemos pintado del lado izquierdo
todo nuevamente si queremos pensar en
los dos posibles en las dos posibles
formas en las que uno
puede tener su valor de spin entonces
tenemos de estos dos distintos números
cuánticos de espín verdad uno sería un
medio positivo y el otro sería un medio
negativo así que tenemos tenemos estos
cuatro números cuánticos y que vamos a
estar utilizando para pensar en los
electrones y sus orbitales